biden's pick for attorney general vowing
to prioritize civil rights combat
extremist attacks
and ensure the justice department
remains politically independent
merrick garland faced questions from
senators during today's
confirmation hearing correspondent david
spont shows us tonight from capitol hill
today i am nominating chief judge
merrick brian garland
five years after republicans refused to
consider him for the supreme court
those same republicans praised federal
appeals court
judge merrick garland i think you have a
very
deep understanding of the threats
america faces
if confirmed garland would lead a
department rife with political divisions
following a four-year period with four
attorneys general at the helm
there have been few moments in history
where the role of attorney general and
the occupant of that post
have mattered more garland promised to
fully prosecute those responsible for
storming the u.s capitol on january 6th
his first priority receiving a briefing
about that day
we must do everything in the power of
the justice department to prevent
this kind of interference with the
policies
of american democratic institutions we
are facing a more dangerous period than
we faced in oklahoma city
and garland would know he oversaw the
prosecution team of oklahoma city bomber
timothy mcveigh
republicans on the judiciary committee
pressed garland
to commit to investigations initiated
during the bill barr
era including special counsel john
durham's investigation
looking at the origins of the russia
probe i don't have any reason to think
that he should not remain in place texas
senator ted cruz
pressed the judge over concerns about a
potential conflict of interest
involving a reported federal
investigation into the nursing home
scandal
surrounding new york governor andrew
cuomo
i don't know any of the facts but i can
guarantee you that somebody with the
conflict of interest will not be the
person running an investigation of any
kind
the justice department is also
investigating the president's
son hunter biden for his business
dealings overseas
have you discussed this hunter biden
case
with the president or anyone else i have
not
david weiss the trump-era u.s attorney
in delaware investigating hunter biden
will stay on and continue his
investigation merrick garland said today
in front of the world to see that he
will be an attorney general
representing all americans not president
biden
brett davis bond in the hearing room
david thanks